this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the One-Stop shop that lets you make a
website of your very own to engage with
your audience and then Spruce it up with
pretty effects and layouts and even sell
your merch on there like socks if you're
selling socks if you've ever wanted to
make a website that you can call your
own then I highly suggest following in
my footsteps and giving Squarespace a
try especially if you're into making
gaming content you can even check out my
fantastic new website in the description
if you fancy they've got tons of super
easy templates to work off of if you
need some inspiration and extremely cool
ways to host your content on the website
or embed any video anywhere and even
remonetize it all all 100 through your
website on Squarespace and stay on top
of your website visits with their
insightful analytics so you know exactly
how many people are visiting from where
and even better you can try Squarespace
out for free for 14 days then when
you're ready to launch your amazing new
site you can head to squarespace.com
Bandit for 10 off the first purchase so
what are you waiting for
so the other day some Zelda content
creators and Outlets were invited to
actually play Tears of the Kingdom early
and make content reviewing their
experiences not me though and I'm not
salty about it not one bit but you know
luck aside it was extremely cool and
exciting to see all of the new things
you can do in the gameplay of Tears of
the Kingdom so I figured I'd compose a
list of the top 5 biggest and most
exciting gameplay changes coming in
tears of the Kingdom based off of how
numa's gameplay and the new preview
gameplay from creators like Celtic and
on that note if you don't want any
spoilers about the game at all including
those regarding gameplay consider this
your spoiler warning for the gameplay
first up and perhaps most importantly
tears of the kingdom does not feature
the Chica first up and perhaps most
importantly tears of the kingdom does
not feature the Chica slate or at least
not the same one that link had in breath
of the wild I'm sure this new Nintendo
switch looking thing he's holding in the
trailer has something to do with that
though it may be an upgrade to the Chica
slate who knows but regardless it
doesn't seem like he uses it in gameplay
which means that this is bigger than you
might have thought at first because the
sheikah Slate was everything it was
magnesis it was crionas it was stasis it
was the camera it was your map and it
was the bombs which means that all of
this is gone including the square bombs
which is a true tragedy this changes the
gameplay of breath of the wild from the
ground up saving only Link's basic
movement and climbing ability in its
place though as you likely know link
will be given new slash ancient zonai
abilities as a result of his new zonai
arm and we know this arm technology is
zonai in origin because the ancient
zonai constructs possess some of the
same abilities like fuse and speaking of
the abilities something tells me we're
not gonna miss the old chica runes too
much ultrahand is essentially magnesis
done better because now you can
manipulate not just metal objects but
nearly any object that isn't nailed to
the ground in zeltic's words and even
stick them together with green zonai
super glue fuse is similar to ultra hand
but specifically works by only sticking
or fusing two objects together such as a
metal bike ball to your Shield or a
confusing flower to your arrow or a
stick to your stick which has many
applications in combat and exploration
recall replaces stasis by rewinding an
object through time and then even
holding it in stasis after it's been
rewound all the way given there's more
time left on the recall ability crionus
is gone of course but in its place we
have Ascend which ascends link upward
through whatever material he can reach
instead of ascending ice out of water
it's not a direct replacement to crionus
like the other two but its applications
are much much bigger than anything
crionus was ever able to do not
including glitches of course the map
system seems to have more or less made
an exact comeback with a few changes to
the UI here and there looking across the
top of the screen it's clear that the
map is still chica in origin so perhaps
Link's new Nintendo switch chica slate
is still the Chica slate but without any
runes in only the map the one Rune that
wasn't directly replaced would be the
bombs at least as far as we know but
this isn't too big of a deal because of
the next big gameplay change which leads
me to the next point the change to
breath of the Wild's quick swapping
interface as you'll recall breath of the
wild allowed players to hold down the
era buttons while pushing left or right
on the right thumbstick in order to swap
between weapons and shields this is
making a comeback in tears of the
Kingdom but with one new much needed
change and one new addition entirely the
change is that you can now drop items
directly from your swap screen which is
a godsend might I add I can't tell you
how many times I'd come across a new
weapon that I couldn't pick up and then
I had to either swap to something I
wanted to throw or pull up the menu and
choose a shield or bow to drop manually
I know it's not that big of a deal but
still it gets old after a while now
though you can just press a button and
boom it's out of your inventory and
lying on the ground in front of you it's
that simple the addition to the swap
mechanic would be the brand new
ingredient tab which allows you to you
guessed it swap between ingredients just
like you would with weapons or Shields
now if you haven't seen all the gameplay
stuff you might be wondering how would
this help in any way well in the first
place it's necessary for using fuse in
combat you can swap to an ingredient you
want to stick to your arrow on the spot
or drop an ingredient or even weapon
that you want to fuse to your weapon or
Shield you can also throw things from
your ingredient inventory which not only
replaces bombs since there are now
ingredients like bomb flowers but adds a
whole new Spectrum to the gameplay
because now link can just Chuck out fire
and ice and electricity bomb balls left
and right without expending a single
Arrow we'll still have to figure out how
to win bomb though which might be a bit
tricky but I have faith in you guys
third the enemies and tears of the
Kingdom have been replaced even though
many of them are making a direct return
which no doubt has helped with the whole
tears of the kingdom is Just Breath of
the wild DLC debate which is by
definition a very ridiculous debate
again as zeltic stated in his gameplay
preview video enemies now drop items
that link can potentially use to upgrade
or simply repair his weapons this adds a
whole new layer to kneading or even just
being willing to kill every enemy you
come across since you'll no longer be
just destroying weapons left and right
who knows you may kill an enemy and
stick their horn on your nearly broken
Greatsword making it a fully restored
and more powerful than ever horny
Greatsword I I'm sorry I I had to not to
mention the construct trucks Drop Zone
eye charges which are useful in trading
for other Zona construction pieces which
are useful in navigating the new world
of Tears of the Kingdom Hyrule so you
know enemies got quite the update there
are also many brand new types of enemies
which I'm sure we haven't even scratched
the surface of yet there are read ads
that we've yet to see link fight which
no doubt will come with different
versions new big bacolins called boss
mccobbins which implies there might even
be boss versions of other enemies like
boss moblins or boss lionels and a whole
bunch of new really scary looking bosses
for link to face off against which will
each come with their materials and
fusible item drops so enemies are likely
going to feel almost entirely different
in tears of the Kingdom fourth if you
would consider leaving a like on this
video that would be greatly appreciated
and it would really help spread it
around on YouTube and you should totally
subscribe if you haven't already because
there will be tons of Tears of the
Kingdom coverage right here in the
months to come okay but for real now
fourth the map is going to be
ridiculously massive if you've been
paying attention to more than just the
trailers and gameplay you probably know
that there have been a couple of ads
that Nintendo has put out for the game
and one of these ads has link lighting
up some underground section looking at
Link's minimap we can even see that
there are now coordinates with X Y and Z
axes so that you can accurately
triangulate your location in the world
because it's so massive you can even see
how the map is going to reflect this new
humongous change similarly to Elden ring
there are tabs on the left side that
will enable you to switch between the
sky surface and presumably underground
Maps Each of which may be just as big as
one another which the more you think
about it the more mind-blowing that fact
becomes not to mention the already
existing surface of Hyrule that yes is
coming over from breath of the wild but
is almost inch by inch completely redone
aonuma stated in his gameplay video that
there are so many changes to the world
of Hyrule he doesn't have time to even
go into it much at all and in every shot
of the world we can see in any trailer
or any piece of gameplay we can see that
this is very much so the case so you bet
a large portion of Tears of the Kingdom
will not only be exploring all the new
areas above and beneath Hyrule but also
rediscovering Hyrule itself elf and
hopefully figuring out why mushroom
Fashion Is All the Rage now in hatteno
Village last but certainly not least
because this is actually one of the
biggest changes for me personally is the
fact that in tears of the Kingdom
completely unlike breath of the wild we
will actually be playing as link as he
progresses through a story and I'm not
saying breath of the wild didn't have a
great story it absolutely did it's just
that 99 of it happened all in the past
as the Calamity nearly ended all of
existence and by the time we get to play
as the reawakened link it's pretty much
all said and done so much so that you
could even complete the game right off
the bat in tears of the Kingdom we won't
be referring to the upheaval as
something that happened 100 years ago or
so we will actually be living and
playing through it meaning characters we
meet will be in cut scenes that we will
feel more connected to as well as having
a real intelligent villain to learn
about and fight against that's actually
formidable for a change a very welcome
change needless to say I am very much so
looking forward to the new story that we
will get to experience firsthand in
tears of the Kingdom before before we
end though an honorable mentioned
gameplay change that's more of
speculation but is still worth
mentioning is that in one of the ads for
tears of the Kingdom as link is shown
facing off against a flame gliac we can
see that he has 17 hearts in a single
row now in breath of the wild a row of
Hearts was limited to 15. this begs the
question have the rose been limited to
just one row now for the first time in a
Zelda game or has the limit of Hearts
just gone up and now maybe the rose
themselves can go up to 20 each making
the total 40 instead of 30. of course
there's no way to know presently which
is why this is just an honorable mention
but either way it does seem that Link's
own physical upgrades have undergone
some changes as well but enough of what
I'm excited for what are you excited
about are you stoked to see something
else that's different or maybe something
else that's the same like the returning
koroks for instance let me know all
about it in the comments below and once
again thank you so much for watching and
please consider liking the video to get
it spread around on YouTube and
subscribe if you haven't already for
much more gaming lore you can always
unsubscribe later huge thanks as always
to my Bandit crew who make my day every
day be sure to follow me on my socials
and that's all she wrote this is Bandit
signing out peace
[Music]